we've really got to work on your solo
gliding there bud
toothless how to train your dragon 2
takes place five years later
dragons are now fully integrated into
the lifestyle unbelievable
the theme of it is so universal it's not
tied to any specific
culture today it's this romanticized
viking culture of a bygone era
and the idea that dragons exist in so
many different cultures around the world
i think people just connect to that wish
fulfillment
it's been pushing the limits of what's
possible with flight
people really love the wish fulfillment
of a dragon pal
and something you can crawl into the
back of and fly around
i think we depict it as something that
could have happened that this was a
period in history where
these animals roam the earth and it
makes people want to spend
time in that fictional era come on bud
hold on we discovered on the first movie
that
3d could actually be used as a
storytelling tool knowing that
we went into this next installment
planning on moments where we would be
able to use the 3d as a tool
that brings the audience closer to an
emotional moment as much as to kind of
stir and heighten your senses when
they're out flying
i personally am so blown away by the
caliber of the work that's been created
for this movie
we've gained a lot of new technology
now the animators are able to create in
a very intuitive
way they can manipulate the characters
live
on their tablets with a stylus and it
feels like stop-motion animation that
way
the lighting has become much more
sophisticated and so we're able to take
our world which is caricatured
and it has a whimsy to it
are you kidding me but render it in such
a believable way
i think seeing the breath it's
overwhelming
people really love the world and they
love the characters and they want more